ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTONAL
AMENDMENTS WILL COME TO ORDER.
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVE IN
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES THEY MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND HERE
TO SOCIAL TO SIXTEEN AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
HOLDENER COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE
IN THE CAPITAL WITH ONE
COMMITTEE MEMBER PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY ARE MEMBER ATTENDING
REMOTELY TODAY SENATOR CONNIE
LEYVA. SENATOR AS A REMINDER
PLEASE MOVE YOUR PHONE OR
COMPUTERS THIS WILL GREATLY AID
IN ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. PASSED IT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT
YOU USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH
TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK
A POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR
ASKING IF YOU'D LIKE TO ON MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT THE ME BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING. R. I. T.
PERSONNEL PUT YOU BACK ON ME
WHEN YOUR DONE. ONCE RECOGNIZED
TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT
YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN.
STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN YOU ARE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WITH
IT ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. PRO INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL BE-DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT. NOW TODAY'S
PACIFIC NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. THE ACCESS CODE IS THREE
FIVE THREE ONE TWO EIGHT THREE.
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE. AND
OR ARE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. ONLY
MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR STYLE
ONE AND ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS COULD BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE ON MUTE AND READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING.
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
SUPPORT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL.
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE BE IN
SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS HE DID. WE WANT BILL
ON OUR AGENDA TODAY BUT BEFORE
WE HEAR THAT BILL ALLOTS
ESTABLISH A QUORUM CONSULTING
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GLAZER PRESENT LASER PRESENT
NIELSEN. THAT'S NIELSEN PRESENT
HERTZBERG. LEYVA WE'RE LEAVING
HERE NEWMAN PRESENT HUMAN
PRESENCE. OKAY QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED LET'S HEAR FROM OUR
AUTHOR SENATOR MAN WHO PROVED
PRESENTING HIS BILL REMOTELY
TODAY WELCOME CENTER MAN- THERE
IS A- A COUPLE NOTES IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS REGARDING
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS AND I'VE- APPRECIATED
AT IN YOUR TESTIMONY SHOULD
INDICATE WHAT YOU ACCEPT THOSE
AMENDMENTS. AND WITH THAT WE
PRESENT TO GIVE YOU THE FLOOR
HELLO LET ME MENTION BEFORE THAT
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE WITNESSES
ON BOTH SIDES WERE GONNA LIMIT
WITNESSES TO TWO MINUTES EACH.
AND TOTAL TESTIMONY ON EACH SIDE
TO TWENTY MINUTES SO THAT
SENATOR BOB MAN WELCOME. AND YOU
CAN BE YES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURST FIRST I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL AND TO YOUR POINT MISTER
CHAIR I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED BY
COMMITTEE STAFF. ON PAGES SIX
AND SEVEN OF THE ANALYSIS TO
CLARIFY THAT SB TWO EIGHTY SIX
WOULD APPLY TO ELECTIONS FOR
SEATS ON THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD
OF EDUCATION. DO TO TIME
CONSTRAINTS THESE AMENDMENTS
WILL BE MADE IN THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. THIS
BILL IS BASED ON A VERY SIMPLE
PROPOSITION ONE THAT'S ACCEPTED
AROUND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
THE COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION
ARE CRITICAL IN CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT GOVERNMENTAL
INSTITUTIONS AND THAT THEREFORE
THE ELECTIONS FOR THE SHOULD BE
HELD DURING THE GENERAL ELECTION
CYCLE WHEN TURNOUT IS AT ITS
HIGHEST RATHER THAN DURING A LOW
TURNOUT PRIMARY AS IS THE
PRACTICE IN ORANGE COUNTY TODAY.
SB TWO EIGHTY SIX WOULD BRING
ORANGE COUNTY IN LINE WITH THE
REST OF CALIFORNIA I WAS THERE
ONLY FIVE COUNTIES INCLUDING
ORANGE COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA THAT
WILL BETTER BOARD OF EDUCATION
ELECTIONS DURING THE PRIMARY.
NOW I'VE TALKED TO MANY
CONSTITUENTS ARE CONFUSED OR
FRUSTRATED BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
SELECTION OF THEIR BOARD OF
EDUCATION TRUSTEE SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEY DID NOT VOTE IN THE PRIMARY
ELECTION. TURNOUT DIFFERENTIALS
BETWEENPRIMARY ELECTIONS AND
GENERAL ELECTIONS ARE STARK AS
WE EXPECT IN TWENTY TWENTY FOR
EXAMPLE IN ORANGE COUNTY EIGHT
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN THOUSAND VOTERS
PARTICIPATE IN THE PRIMARY
ELECTION AS OPPOSED TO ALMOST
ONE POINT FIVE FIVE MILLION
VOTERS IN THE GENERAL ELECTION.
AND NEARLY TWO FOLD INCREASE
THESE TURNOVER DIFFERENTIALS ARE
PARTICULARLY PRONOUNCED AMONG
RACIAL AND ETHNIC MINORITIES.
IMMIGRANTS AND YOUNG PEOPLE.
COUNTY BOARD. SIR CRITICAL. IN
ARKHAM. I PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
ISSUE DISTRICTS. EDUCATING
STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS AND
PROVIDING DIRECT SERVICES TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. THAT'S WHY
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE MAKE
EVERY EFFORT TO MAKE SURE THAT
VOTERS AREN'T FRANCHISE. BUT
THEY'RE ENGAGED IN THE ELECTION
OF THESE CRITICAL LOCAL
GOVERNING BOARDS. CURRENTLY IN
THE ARCHIVER EDUCATION HOLDS
ELECTIONS FOR BOARD SEATS DURING
THE PRIMARY. I AS I MENTIONED
THAT IS LOWER AND THIS PRACTICE
IS DIFFERENT FROM THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF COUNTY
BOARD OF EDUCATION. I THESE TURN
OUT DIFFERENCES SHOALS ARE
PARTICULARLY PRONOUNCED ON
RACIAL ETHNIC MINORITIES. YOUNG
PEOPLE AND LOW PROPENSITY VOTERS
AND IS WELL DOCUMENTED THAT
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
VOTERS. YOUNGER VOTERS BETWEEN
AGES EIGHTEEN TO THIRTY FIVE AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN ASIAN AMERICAN
LATINO VOTERS. I SEE A
PARTICULARLY STARK DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THEIR PARTICIPATION IN
PRIMARY VERSUS GENERAL
ELECTIONS. SB TWO EIGHTY SIX
WOULD REQUIRE THAT ELECTIONS FOR
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD. OF
EDUCATION BE CONSOLIDATED WITH
THE STATEWIDE GENERAL ELECTION
IN NOVEMBER. AND WOOD BASICALLY
APPLY THE SAME ELECTION TIME
LINES CURRENTLY IN PLACE FOR
ALMOST ALL OF THE COUNTY BOARD
OF EDUCATION STATE. THIS IS A
LOCAL ELECTION BILL THAT WOULD
INCREASE VOTER PARTICIPATION.
FOR A CRITICAL BODY AND WOULD
REDUCE AND LET. BOATER CONFUSION
BY CREATING UNIFORMITY AROUND
THE TIMING OF ELECTIONS. ON THE
LINE TO TESTIFYING SUPPORT WE
HAVE BARBEL SHOWMAN SETTLE BACK
VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
BOARD MEMBER. AND ELIZABETH
DORAN PARKER PAST PRESIDENT. OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY SCHOOL BOARD'S
ASSOCIATION. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
SENATOR MEN SO LET'S GO YOUR
LEAD WITNESSES- I DO PRESENTE IN
ORDER OUT FOR YOUR- AND INVITING
BARBER SHOREMEN FROM- TO SPEAK
FIRST. THE SHOWMAN THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MY
NAME IS BARBARA SOWN AND BOARD
MEMBER OF SADDLEBACK VALLEY. AND
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO PASS SENATE
BILL TWO EIGHTY SIX FOR THE
BENEFIT OF ALL VOTERS IN ORANGE
COUNTY. THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD
OF EDUCATION RACE SHOULD BE HELD
IN NOVEMBER INSTEAD OF WHEN THE
PRIMARIES ARE. THE MAJORITY OF
COUNTY OFFICES ARE IN THE
NOVEMBER GENERAL ELECTION AND
THEY'RE ALMOST 50% MORE VOTERS
IN GENERAL ELECTIONS. AND
PRIMARIES AND I BELIEVE THE
ORANGE COUNTY SCHOOL BOARD
ELECTION SHOULD BE ALSO. THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT OFFICE AND IT
DESERVES A HIGHER NUMBER OF
PEOPLE CASTING BALLOTS. ANOTHER
PROBLEM WITH HAVING THIS
IMPORTANT ELECTION WANT THE
PRIMARIES. IS IT MANY VOTERS DO
NOT REALIZE THIS IS A ONE AND
DONE RIGHT. THEY BELIEVE THEY
ARE VOTING AND THE TWO
CANDIDATES WITH THE HIGHEST
VOTES WILL BE IN THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION. LIKE ALL OTHER RACES
ON THE BALLOT WITH PRIMARIES BUT
THIS IS NOT TRUE SENATORS.
ORANGE COUNTY SCHOOL BOARD WHICH
REPRESENTS ALMOST THIRTY
DISTRICTS SHOULD BE CONSOLIDATED
WITH THE STATEWIDE GENERAL
ELECTIONS IN NOVEMBER. I AM
SAYING PLEASE AND THANK YOU AT
THE SAME TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS SHERMAN GO TO THE
SECOND- THE WITNESS ELIZABETH
DORAN PARKER PARKER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU TO YOU KNOW I
WAS A MEMBER OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION FOR
THIRTY TWO YEARS AND HELD
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS FOR ELECTED
BOARD MEMBERS AT THE LOCAL STATE
AND NATIONAL LEVEL FOR THIRTY
YEARS DO WE DO WITH KNOWLEDGE
HOW LITTLE IS UNDERSTOOD ARE
KNOWN ABOUT THE CRITICAL
LEADERSHIP FOR. COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION THIRD WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM EXCEPT FOR JUVENILE
JUSTICE SCHOOL AND COMMUNITY
SCHOOL. BOARDS HAVE VERY
DIFFERENT RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THOSE OF LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS AS
DEFINED IN AT COULD SECTIONS TEN
FOURTEEN TEN FORTY TWO THE ONLY
ELECTED BOARDS THE FOCUS ON THE
NEEDS OF STUDENTS AND COMMUNITY
IN JUVENILE JUSTICE FOR OUR
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION. THE
CHILDREN IN THE SCHOOLS ARE OUR
MOST VULNERABLE THEY TEND TO
INCLUDE A MUCH HIGHER PERCENTAGE
OF HOMELESS FOSTER YOUTH LGBTQ
PLUS CHILDREN KICKED OUT OR
DROPPED OUT THERE FOR THE NEW
TRUSTEE TO CRY. YOUR EDUCATION
SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL NEEDS TO
ENSURE OUR MOST AT PROMISE
CHILDREN HAVE ELECTED BOARD OF
EDUCATION TRUSTEE HYPER FOCUSED
ON YOUR WELL BEING THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF VOTERS NEED TO ELECT
THEM IN ORANGE COUNTY IN
PARTICULAR MOVING THE ELECTION
FROM UKIAH VERY SOON OF EMBERS
GENERAL ELECTION WILL INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF VOTERS ELECTING
TRUSTEES FOR THESE CHILDREN. THE
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF THESE
CHILDREN'S LIVES IN
TRADITIONALLY DISENFRANCHISED
COMMUNITY AND MANY NEED BE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION
FOR THE MORE VOTERS TO
UNDERSTAND THEIR CHALLENGES AND
LIVED EXPERIENCES THE MORE
LIKELY THEY WILL ELECT
EDUCATIONAL WINGERS WHO
UNDERSTAND AND PRIORITIZE THEIR
NEEDS. WHEN I BEGAN MY TENURE IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO ON THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION
NONE OF US APPRECIATED HOW MUCH
IT MATTERED WHO VOTED IN SAID
THE IMPORTANCE OF THESE
TRUSTEES. ADULT ADDING A VERY.
PERSPECTIVE FROM MY KERR
EXPERIENCE IT. IS NEAR AND- TO
GO ANY REAL HE'S UNDER. HOW THIS
RACE IS WHAT I REFERRED AS A AND
DONE IN THE- BECAUSE OF RECORD.
HELP RAY ARE THAT PRIME TO THE
REAL WAY THE- THIS BILL WILL BE
. THIS CAN. EVERY VOTER ANDERSON
THAT ONE AND DONE A POOL OUTING
. WILL BE VOTED IN THE J. LIKE
ALL OF THE OTHER ONE AND DONE
EDUCATIONAL BOARD GREAT IT'S- AN
ORANGE COUNTY. THANK YOU I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS PARKER. WE'RE GONNA GO
TO WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM- FORTY
TWO OH THREE THIRTY FOLKS WHO
WANT TO TESTIFY SEEN NINE WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF SB TWO EIGHTY SIX
AND WILL ASK THEM TO JUST GIVE
THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION. AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. THANK YOU
TO STATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
USING YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
USING YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
PLEASE. THANK YOU MR SURE THERE
ARE NO MINES IN Q. LET'S JUST
GIVE IT ONE LAST SHOT AT ASK ONE
MORE TIME IF THERE IS ANYBODY
WISHES TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. IF
YOU LIKE TO STATE SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE
HAVE NO LINES GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO THE OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL NOW. LIKE TO ASK IF THERE'S
ANYBODY HERE AND ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE WISHES HE CAN
OPPOSITION TO SO INDICATE. C.
NINE WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE UP.
MODERATOR WOULD YOU ASK IF THERE
IS ANYONE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION S. B. TWO EIGHTY SIX
TO PLEASE SO INDICATE. THANK YOU
THE STATE OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. I COMMAND AGAIN IS THE
NUMBER ONE AND THEN ZERO USING
YOUR TELEPHONE. REPEAT THE
INSTRUCTIONS TO STATE OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE HAVE NO LINES IN Q.
ALL RIGHT BARBARA THANK YOU WERE
GOING TO BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THANK
YOU TO SENTIMENT RAMOS BUILT- IT
VERY QUICKLY WANTTO NOTE THAT
THE- COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS POINTS
OUT THAT IN THEORY- THERE SAID
THE POTENTIAL FOR LOCAL REMEDY-
UNDER EXISTING LAW- BUT I CAN
TELL YOU FROM HAVING BEEN IN
CLOSE PROXIMITY. TO COUNTY BOARD
OF ELECTIONS IN ORANGE COUNTY-
FOR SOME TIME THAT THAT IS NOT
LIKELY TO HAPPEN MALPRACTICE.
LESS OF A BUG THAN A FEATURE OF
THE CURRENT SYSTEM AND THAT IS
WHY I'M GLAD TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL TODAY- AND I'D LIKE TO MOVE
IT WHEN THE TIME TO APPROPRIATE.
THAT ANY. OTHER MEMBERS COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT-
SENTIMENT THAT YOU FOR YOUR WORK
IN THIS AREA I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU NEVER THIS BILL TO- TO
ORANGE COUNTY WE'VE HAD A NUMBER
OF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IT OVER
THE COURSE OF THE- PAST YEAR-
THAT I'M- I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY. HI I THINK THAT
THE A LOT OF DIFFERENT SHOULD GO
TO REPRESENTATIVES FROM THEIR
AREA AND YOU AND YOUR COLLEAGUES
HAVE MADE IT CLEAR THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SEE. HAPPEN I KNOW THAT- A
COUPLE OBSERVATIONS IRRESPECTIVE
OF THAT ONE IS THAT. IT
TYPICALLY WOULD WOULD LIKE TO
SEE EFFORTS CONCRETE EFFORTS
MADE TO MAKE THESE TYPES OF
CHANGES ON THE LOCAL LEVEL IT'S
NOT CLEAR TO ME THAT ANY MOTIONS
BEEN PUT BEFORE THE BOARD.
PASTOR DEFEATED TO- TO ADVANCE
THIS AND THAT THAT'S ALWAYS AT
MY VIEW OF. A BEST PRACTICE TO
TRY TO. EXHAUST THOSE REMEDIES
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL- SECOND AND
THIS GOES BEYOND THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE AN ORANGE COUNTY BUT- I
CERTAINLY KNOWLEDGE THAT- AND
NOVEMBER ELECTION HAS A MUCH
GREATER TURNOUT. BUT THERE IS
ANOTHER UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
THAT COME OUT OF THAT.
CIRCUMSTANCE ONE IS THAT YOU
LOOK AT THE DROP OFF ON THE
BALLOT FROM THE TOP OF THE
BALLOT TO THE BOTTOM. AND I
THINK THAT IN. MOST CASES IN
GENERAL ELECTIONS YOU SEE A
SIGNIFICANT DROP OFF. DOESN'T
MEAN THAT EVEN WITH THE DROP OFF
THE PARTICIPATION LEVEL IS STILL
GREATER IN A GENERAL ELECTION IT
COULD VERY WELL STILL BE.
GREATER BUT PART OF THE EASON
THAT THAT THAT DROP OFF HAPPENS.
IS BECAUSE THE- THE ATTENTION
PAID TO THESE LOWER TIER OFFICES
IN GENERAL ELECTIONS IS
SUBSTANTIALLY DIMINISHED. AND
THE COST OF CAMPAIGNING IN THE
GENERAL ELECTION IS
SUBSTANTIALLY HIGHER. THE DALLAS
IS POINTS OUT THE DIFFERENCE IN
TURNOUT. AB TWEEN THE PRIMARY
AND GENERAL IN ORANGE COUNTY AND
IT'S A SUBSTANTIAL DIFFERENCE
BUT IT'S ALSO A SUBSTANTIAL
DIFFERENCE IN THE COST OF
CAMPAIGNING ON THAT
JURISDICTION'S. WE COMPLAIN A
LOT ABOUT THE MONEY AND POLITICS
. AND YET- CIRCUMSTANCES LIKE
THIS MAKE IT EVEN MORE
EXPENSIVE. AND SO IT'S A
CHALLENGE HOW DO WE GET GREATER
COVERAGE OF THESE RACES.
WITNESSES AND I KNOW THE AUTHOR
MAKE IT CLEAR HOW IMPORTANT THIS
ELECTION IS FOR THIS PARTICULAR
POSITION- AND YT. WE STRUGGLE
TO GET ANY ATTENTION. AND I
THINK IF YOU SURVEYED THOSE WHO
RUN FOR THE BOARD OF EDUCATION
NOT JUST IN ORANGE COUNTY BUT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. YOU'LL
HEAR THE CHALLENGES THEY FACE IN
GETTING THEIR MESSAGE OUT. IT'S
A IT'S AN ONGOING CHALLENGE SO.
I THINK THERE ARE SOME
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AS WE
CONSOLIDATE- NEVERTHELESS I'M
RESPECTFUL OF THE LOCAL.
LEADERSHIP'S DESIRE TO MOVE IT
AND WITH SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
SO WITHOUT ANY FURTHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS. ALLOW SENATOR MANY
CLOSE. THANK YOU GENTLEMEN FOR
YOUR SUPPORT I THANK YOU CHAIR
MISTER CHAIR FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL
COMMENTS AND FOR YOUR SUPPORT AS
YOU MENTIONED THIS IS A LOCAL
ELECTIONS BILL AND HAS NO FORMAL
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. PERFECT THANK YOU
SENATOR MADAM I RECOGNIZE THE
MOTION FROM SENATOR NEWMAN. THIS
IS DUE PASS- THERE ARE KNOWN AND
SO THOUGH THE AUTHORS AGREED TO
TAKE AMENDMENTS. AND WITH THAT
AS THE CONSOLE TO TAKE THE ROLE
. SB TWO EIGHT SIX THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
GLAZER HI GLAZER HI NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
BY LEYVA SENATOR LEYVA SB TWO
EIGHTY SIX HI. RIVER BY NEWMAN
AYE NEWMAN FIVE I THAT THAT BILL
IS OUT FOUR TO ONE I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
TESTIFIED TO TODAY IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS
AND CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS.
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD THANK
YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE PARTICIPATED TODAY ARE
WONDERFUL CONSULTING TEAM. BY
THAT BUT THAT BOOKS THAT
INCLUDES OUR MEETING AT THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS
AND REAPPORTIONMENT-
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS AND WE
ARE ADJOURNED.